sculptures paintings and other unique
pieces in the indonesian capital and
hundreds of people taking a look the
country's art scene appears to be
roaring back to life after surviving a
two-year hiatus due to covert
the most important thing is
to show that the art market is strong
that there is demand
and that
collectors are back buying art estee
nurijaden owns a gallery in south
jakarta she says many artworks need to
be seen in person to be fully
appreciated if you're here you know the
depth you can see and then you can
imagine if this work you know
will be shown at your place or your
someone's office or a collector's house
at this year's fair there's a greater
focus on artworks from bali as a way of
supporting artists and galleries there
many on the island faced financial
hardship when covert 19 prevented
tourists from visiting
as in many countries indonesia's visual
arts scene was hit hard by the pandemic
galleries were closed and had to exhibit
their collections online now with the
return of one of the region's largest
art festivals many are optimistic about
the industry's revival
more than 60 galleries from indonesia
and elsewhere in asia are participating
eager to meet collectors and artists
from around the world
in person
[Music]
it's not only the artists but those who
display art like galleries and art
management everyone is excited to work
together again
while many celebrate a return to the way
things were there's also room for
incarnations not seen before nfts are at
the fair for the first time non-fungible
tokens are one-of-a-kind digital assets
usually paid for with cryptocurrency
bali-based french artist cyril congo
known for his distinct graffiti style is
branching into nfts
yeah it's the new process for me that's
the
that
the new currencies
new process
yeah it's really exciting
you have to to put your brain on it
to put the energy
with new artists new modes and new
pieces on display the fair is a dynamic
celebration of the resilience of the
industry and the tantalizing hints of
what's yet to come jessica washington al
jazeera jakarta